[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 5 avril voici le programme
de ce soir à la veille d'une onzième
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites ce jeudi 6 avril
la première ministre a tenté de renouer
le dialogue avec les 8 principales
organisations syndicales après une heure
de discussion l'Inter syndicale déplore
un échec devant le refus sans surprise
d'Elizabeth borne de revenir sur le
projet de loi quelles sont les
perturbations à prévoir demain dans les
Yvelines on fait le point dans cette
émission Paris camembert ce nom vous dit
peut-être quelque chose je parle ici de
la course cycliste de 200 km qui relie
l'Île-de-France à la Normandie et
Magnanville redevient la ville de départ
après une interruption de huit ans parmi
les participants quelques noms connus
nacerbois ni Donavan Grondin et
Guillaume Martin nous en parlerons avec
Michel Le boucle le maire de Magnanville
il est notre invité et enfin c'est le
retour de la chronique éducation dans
votre 7 8 avec notre journaliste Régine
ralech ce soir elle vous parlera de la
forest internationale school situé à
Mareil-Marly le principe dispensé des
cours dans la forêt mais pas que les
détails dans cette émission avec la
fondatrice de cette école Julie Muller
et avec nous en plateau ce soir Joël
jegousseau bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
êtes le nouveau secrétaire du Parti
communiste français dans les Yvelines ce
matin suite à la réunion entre la
première ministre et les 8 syndicats
Fabien Roussel le secrétaire national du
PCF a déclaré je cite face à la
radicalisation du gouvernement répondons
lui en manifestants massivement demain
dans tout le pays
radicalisation du gouvernement ce ne
sont pas des mots un peu trop fort j'ai
envie de dire non les syndicats avaient
prévenu ils avaient tous
à cette réunion en parlant d'une voix
qui voulait
abandonner cette cette condre réforme je
crois que voilà ils ont raison donc les
mots de Fabien Roussel ne sont pas ne
sont pas forts et c'est la main est
aujourd'hui au gouvernement et il veut
pas entendre
les la rue et notamment l'union de tous
les syndicats qui lui demandent de
retirer sa loi donc non on
radicalisation non c'est pas c'est pas
d'autres d'autant que cette loi a été
imposée par le 49-3 il y a eu que 50
jours pour
aborder cette loi à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat qui est très court en
terminant à chaque fois d'ailleurs avant
l'heure habituel à minuit alors que des
débats arrivent des fois vers deux
heures trois heures du matin pour pour
aborder des grandes questions comme
celle-là donc non non c'est pas c'est
des propos juste
en détail sur cette réunion qui s'est
déroulée ce matin et qui s'est par un
échec et également sur la mobilisation
dans les Yvelines contre la réforme des
retraites avec nous également à distance
Michel Lebouc bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes le maire de
Magnanville ville où c'est lancera mardi
prochain la mythique course cycliste
Paris camembert ça fait depuis 8 ans
qu'elle ne s'était pas élancée de
Magnanville qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
en tant que mère de réitérer avec cette
tradition puisque Magnanville a
accueilli pendant 20 ans cette course
et ben on a besoin
vous interviewez le secrétaire de la
fédération du Parti communiste des
Yvelines mais dans ce monde où
aujourd'hui on a quand même une crise
sociale et économique et c'est pas le
but de mon sujet aujourd'hui et ben
c'est de donner du bien-être aux gens et
par cette initiative du Paris camembert
initiative très populaire parce que le
vélo est une institution dans les
Yvelines comme vous le savez on est donc
les Yvelines
impliquées dans la construction et des
JO de 2024 même Magnanville nous-mêmes
on est terre de jeu et donc on va
redouer avec cette véritable institution
qui a marqué de son empreinte au
territoire du Mantois pendant une
dizaine d'années voire plus et donc on
l'a perdu comme vous le disiez en
introduction pendant 8 ans et moi je
suis très fier avec mes équipes de
renouer avec cette course mythique qui
est une course professionnelle ou de
grandes équipes de grands coureurs vont
s'affronter pendant 200 km et ça nous
fait vraiment plaisir et on aura
l'occasion d'en parler un peu plus en
détail dans quelques instants avec nous
également un plateau 3 journalistes de
la rédaction de TV 78 Grégory canalet
Céline Charles bonsoir et Régine rallès
bonsoir bonsoir alors Régine vous
revenez nous parler d'éducation dans le
7 8 avec une toute nouvelle chronique et
du Talk c'est un film Mathilde avec
cette nouvelle chronique j'ai pour
ambition de d'aider ou en tout cas
d'inspirer les jeunes dans leur
orientation scolaire et professionnelle
ça sera à travers des témoignages ou
même des reportages mais je voudrais
également éveiller la curiosité des
parents sur des nouvelles techniques
d'apprentissage et même de leur faire
découvrir de nouvelles écoles et donc ce
soir vous allez nous parler de la forest
internationale school tout à fait elle
est basée à Marie Marnie mais je ne vous
en dis pas plus on a hâte d'en savoir
visage en tout cas ce sera tout à
l'heure avec nous donc Céline Charles
comme d'habitude le mercredi vous nous
parlez des sorties ciné à ne pas manquer
durant la semaine de quoi est-ce que
vous allez nous parler ce soir et bien
ce soir on parlera de deux adaptations
très attendues une sur un jeu vidéo très
célèbre et une autre sur un livre tout
aussi célèbre et on terminera avec une
romance à suspense oui vous allez nous
parler de Super Mario Bros je crois
et donc ce sera en fin d'émission restez
bien avec nous Grégory vous vous allez
nous présenter les informations du jour
à retenir dans les Yvelines ce sera dans
quelques instants dans cette émission
également les conseils de professionnels
pour avoir un beau jardin pour ce
printemps un petit time d'exception au
Trianon Palace de Versailles mais avant
tout ça on va jeter un coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin prévoyez vos parapluies
météo France annonce de la pluie sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera 8 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles et
7 degrés à Rambouillet dans l'après-midi
le temps s'améliore du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan avec quelques
éclaircies des averses sont toujours à
prévoir dans le secteur de Versailles et
Rambouillet côté température il fera en
moyenne 11 à 12 degrés dans les Yvelines
et demain nous fêterons la Saint
Marcellin le point maintenant sur les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Grégory canalet on
commence ces informations du jour par
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites
syndical était reçu ce matin par
Elisabeth borne une heure de discussion
qui a abouti selon les huit principaux
syndicats sur un échec la première
ministre refusant de retirer la loi sur
la réforme des retraites des retraites
c'est du coup l'intersyndical appelle je
cite un maximum de travailleurs et
citoyens à manifester demain pour la 11e
journée de mobilisation reste à savoir
si ce sera suivi dans les rues du côté
des transports en revanche pas ou peu de
perturbations annoncées demain jeudi
dans les Yvelines trafic quasi normal
sur le RER B 3 trains sur 4 sur le RER A
et la ligne N du Transilien enfin deux
trains sur trois sons prévus pour les
lignes C JL et U du côté de
l'enseignement quelques perturbations
sont attendues dans les écoles des
collèges et les lycées ainsi que dans
les accueils périscolaires et les
services de cantine n'hésitez pas à
consulter le site Internet de vos
communes et côté mobilisation on peut
déjà citer une première mobilisation ce
mercredi du côté de Versailles ou une
centaine de salariés d'enedis à
manifester en début d'après-midi devant
les grilles de la préfecture donc à
Versailles dans l'actualité également
les crèches franciliennes qui tirent la
sonnette d'alarme depuis plusieurs mois
elles font face et une inquiétante
pénurie de personnel près de la moitié
des crèches collectives seraient
touchées par le phénomène en
Île-de-France et même en France nos
confrères du Parisien ont consacré une
double page sur le sujet dans leur
édition du jour résultat des berceaux
qui ferment et le constat en
Île-de-France était différent la région
à elle seule concentre 75% des places
fermées en crèche en France
l'explication de cette pénurie de
personnel de la petite enfance le manque
d'attractivité des métiers qui
s'étendentifie avec la crise sanitaire
du covid-19 un exemple à la carrière
sous Poissy sur 24 postes d'assistants
maternel à pourvoir actuellement la
ville a pu en recruter un seul on
poursuit avec du football Grégory deux
clubs de football des Yvelines ont été
sélectionnées par le Paris Saint-Germain
il s'agit de l'ES Guyancourt et de l'ES
Sartrouville cette semaine leur
président ont été reçus au Parc des
Princes car leur association ont été
retenues pour le club tour 2023 en clair
pendant les vacances de printemps et des
ateliers et activités créés
spécifiquement par l'équipe du centre de
formation du PSG seront proposés au sein
des deux clubs et je ne pourrons partir
avec un livret des bonnes pratiques du
footballeur et aussi les conseils avisés
des éducateurs parisiens et en tout un
mille jeunes de 10 à 13 ans de 10 clubs
de la région parisienne vont pouvoir en
bénéficier on écoute tout de suite la
réaction du président de l'ES Guyancourt
et d'abord un grand plaisir une chance
certainement d'avoir été retenu on est
plus de 200 inscrits 10 sélectionnés en
Île-de-France c'est une joie immense ça
consiste à faire bénéficier nos jeunes
joueurs filles et garçons d'une d'une
immersion dans univers du PSG 50 enfants
le vendredi 5 mai à partir de 13h30
jusqu'à 18h30 qui vont
bénéficier de d'exercices techniques qui
ont été élaborés par le staff technique
du PSG autre information sport et autres
bonne nouvelle pour Guyancourt la ville
sera traversée par l'épreuve olympique
féminine en ligne de cyclisme sur route
pour Paris 2024 annonce fait hier dans
lors du conseil municipal de la ville le
parcours final est en cours de
validation mais là a duré totale de la
traversée étaitimée environ 15 minutes
l'itinéraire de la course devrait passer
par la rue Louis Blériot et la route
départementale 91 50 en Yvelines sera
décidément la capitale du cyclisme
pendant les Jeux Olympiques les épreuves
de vélo de piste et de BMX seront au
Vélodrome national et le VTT sur la
colline d'Élancourt à Guyancourt il y
aura aussi le golf du côté du golf
national et enfin pour terminer Grégory
le zoo safari de Thoiry vient
d'accueillir de nouveaux pensionnaires
il s'appelle la Tarak du nuac et ulac
des noms d'origine est-ce que vous savez
je crois que j'ai triché un petit peu
Inuit non quelque chose comme ça
c'est le jeudi le quiz c'est dommage ce
sont trois frères ces loups des des
loups du Canada arrivés cette semaine en
provenance de la réserve de la
Haute-Touche dans l'Indre de son gris et
un de couleur crème ils ont été relâchés
dans la réserve américaine du zoo les
canidés ont pris rapidement leur marque
la rencontre avec les ours déjà présents
dans cet espace s'est déroulé sans
accroc pas de panique Mathilde et
bientôt tout ce bonbon sera rejoint par
de nouveau bisons américains merci
beaucoup Grégory canalet pour toutes ces
informations et si vous aussi comme
d'habitude vous voyez une information ou
une image qui vous a marqué près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
[Musique]
le Parti communiste français des
Yvelines un nouveau secrétaire général
fin mars joël jegouzeau a été élu lors
du congrès départemental qui s'est tenu
à limer et il est en plateau avec nous
ce soir on en parlait en début
d'émission à la veille d'une onzième
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites la première
ministre devait ce matin l'Inter sadical
pour tenter de renouer le dialogue après
l'adoption de cette loi de cette réforme
sur la retraite une réunion qui n'a
abouti à rien
Joël Jégou vous espérez toujours que le
gouvernement revienne sur sa réforme des
retraites ah oui on espère pour
l'instant c'est pas le cas mais la
mobilisation elle a grandi jusqu'à
présent il y a une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation qui a encore demain on sait
pas de quel de quel taux elle va elle va
elle va être ceci dit c'est comme un
intéressant de voir c'est pas facile de
faire grève pour les gens c'est pas
facile de manifester et pourtant il y a
eu jusqu'à 3000 3500000 personnes dans
la rue y compris dans les petites villes
quoi ça c'est vraiment intéressant et
c'est un peu nouveau comme les nouveaux
l'Union Syndicale complète depuis le
début quoi vous attendez du coup une
forte mobilisation demain dans les
Yvelines ah bah on espère malgré la
pluie j'ai entendu qu'il allait pleuvoir
mais rien ne nous arrête quels sont les
points de mobilisation dans le
département on a entendu certains tout à
l'heure mais alors il y a eu beaucoup de
mobilisation dans les villes du
département il y a eu notamment à
Conflans c'était une mobilisation un
appel de la nuque il y a eu aussi des
rassemblements politiques à Limay à
Trappes à je ne me souviens plus de nom
à côté de Limay
voilà
très joli Mantes-la-Jolie et il y en a
un qui se prépare aujourd'hui même
voilà et il y a eu des manifestations
syndicales dans l'Union etc
notamment plusieurs amantes puisque tous
les samedis matin les syndicats se
retrouvent pour manifester et un peu
partout dans le département à Versailles
plusieurs rassemblements à Versailles de
très très nombreuses personnes sont des
milliers même en tout à Versailles et
voilà mais vous avez l'impression d'être
entendu parce que quand même du coup
cette réforme sur les retraites elle est
elle est maintenant dans les mains du
Conseil constitutionnel j'ai envie de
dire est-ce que ça sert encore
aujourd'hui de se mobiliser contre ce
projet de loi oui ça sert parce que le
conseil
notamment demander son avis
non va donner son avis pardon sur sur
cette contre-réforme j'appelle ça une
contre-informe ça sera une réforme on en
discuterait là voilà c'est pas une c'est
pas une réforme c'est une contre-réforme
et donc va donner son avis et va donner
son avis notamment sur le rip qui a été
déposé par vers la gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale donc une fois le rip accepté
ce qu'on espère qu'il soit accepté on a
six mois et 9 mois et demi pour
avoir 6 millions 7 si je me souviens
bien de signature donc ça va nous
permettre ensuite de continuer de
discuter avec les gens voilà et vous
pensez que le gouvernement serait
capable de faire marcher machine arrière
parce qu'on a l'impression que c'est
l'objectif en tout cas il y a à peu près
80% des gens qui sont contre donc c'est
pas du tout tenable de la part du
gouvernement qui s'entête voilà c'est
pas tenable alors autre sujet le congrès
du PCF se clôture ce week-end le Congrès
national du PCF se clôture ce week-end
alors vous vous tournez quand même vers
une large réélection de Fabien whes
Roussel c'est ce qui est prévu c'est ce
qui va arriver je pense deux
orientations vont s'imposer vont
s'opposer durant ce congrès national du
PCF continuer à s'allier avec la nuit
épaisse ou faire cavalier
vous êtes plutôt de quel côté alors ça
sera dans les discussions en tout cas
dans le département du point de vue
local on arrive à faire des choses
intéressantes avec toute la nuque
puisqu'on a réussi des réunions
publiques notamment depuis depuis
quelques temps avec l'ensemble de la
nuque qui ont rassemblé beaucoup de
monde où je suis intervenu dans
plusieurs notamment et on a réussi à
élire deux députés quand même donc oui
on espère que voilà nous on est dans le
département on espère que il y a
beaucoup encore de collaboration avec la
nuque mais tout ça oui ça va se décider
au Congrès aussi qu'il y a des il y a
des camarades qui sont pas spécialement
pour voilà les décisions sera prises
vraiment au Congrès et on appliquera
tous la décision qui sera prise par la
majorité au Congrès ça veut dire
aujourd'hui le Parti communiste français
ne peut exister qu'au sein d'une
alliance pour faire entendre sa voix pas
possible d'y aller seul de faire
cavalier seul comme ces Mathilde
je suis pour une union notamment alors
pas seulement avec la nu il faut je si
je l'occasion je dirais je dirais tout à
l'heure ce qui est arrivé avec ce top
galère notamment la bataille qu'on a eu
dans la région parisienne notamment dans
le département mais il faut il faut que
chacun garde son identité c'est ce qu'on
a fait dans les réunions publiques
puisque moi-même j'ai pris la parole
avec nos oppositions à nous donc ça
c'est bien mais il faut pas qu'il y ait
déjà monnaie non plus d'un seul parti et
on est intervenu notamment deux trois
fois parce qu'il y a une tentative
d'hégémonie la France insoumise on a
réglé le problème et aujourd'hui je
pense que ça sera réglé pour les pour
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines et qu'on va pouvoir travailler
en commun ensemble c'est l'objectif
alors plus localement dans les Yvelines
certaines villes anciennement communiste
sont passés à droite comme la verrière
la ville les TPCF de 1977 à 2020 trappe
également qui était PCF de 1944 à 2001
son maire à l'irabet a été soutenu par
le Parti PCF mais il est maintenant sous
l'étiquette génération.s
est-ce que vous avez l'impression de
perdre du terrain dans les Yvelines ah
bah c'est sûr qu'on a perdu du terrain
municipal ça c'est clair mais bon on est
toujours à offensive d'ailleurs on est
le seul parti aujourd'hui
disséminée un peu partout de proximité
dans le dans les départements en général
donc on est la seule organisation réelle
de proximité ce qui nous aide après
voilà à nous faire entendre alors on a
eu certes quelques difficultés on a
quand même garage salut le maire de
Magnanville qui est là ou qui est encore
là peut-être oui voilà
qui a conservé sa mairie et puis le
maire de Limay qui lui-même n'est pas
membre du Parti communiste mais qui se
dit comme parce que la force la force
communiste ça va bien au-delà du Parti
communiste lui-même et puis c'est bien
comme ça et on arrive à travailler avec
d'autres voilà comme ça comment vous
l'expliquez ce recul ont cité l'exemple
de la verrière qui a été pendant plus de
40 ans communiste pire c'est l'incourt
Nelly du tube plus récemment comment
vous expliquer ce recul dans le
département oh bah ça s'explique de
plusieurs plusieurs ça serait sûrement
trop long aujourd'hui
on n'aurait pas assez d'une heure pour
expliquer ça mais mais oui oui on a on a
vécu une période notamment
avec les avec les pays socialistes moi
j'appelle ça un pays socialiste mais qui
se disait qu'il se disait communiste et
qui nous ont un peu plombé jusqu'en dans
les années 90 et ça ça joue encore
aujourd'hui malheureusement et moi avec
mon équipe justement on réfléchit et le
parti aussi réfléchi à ça comment
aujourd'hui on travaille sur les
questions changement de société mais en
se dégageant de tout tout ce qui s'est
passé au 20e siècle dont on considère
que c'était pas du tout du tout
communisme même s'il y a eu quelques
avancées à l'époque alors ça ça nous a
plombé énormément et ça nous plombe
encore aujourd'hui donc il faut tordre
le coup à ça et puis après il y a eu
d'autres phénomènes voilà plus peut-être
plus locale des fois aussi voilà sur des
fois la stratégie voilà ou sur du
contenu mais oui oui on a perdu beaucoup
de terrain malheureusement mais on veut
reconquérir notamment parler de la
verrière tout à l'heure on a vraiment la
volonté de la stratégie c'est quoi du
coup c'est un peu comme ce que fait
Fabien Roussel au niveau national si je
puis dire dépoussiérer un peu le Parti
communiste ah je suis pas si on peut
s'appeler des poussières mais en tout
cas voilà on a on a fait un congrès
justement pour
étaloffensive et créer les conditions
que les communistes soient un peu plus
près enfin présent en tout cas sur le
terrain et puis on a l'avantage si on a
deux ans sans élection donc là pendant
deux ans on va pouvoir travailler les
contenus voir réfléchir encore sur
nous-mêmes travailler cette question de
changement de société on parlait de la
retraite tout à l'heure il y a une
question fondamentale qui se pose sur le
changement de société c'est la question
du travail le sens du travail qu'elle
doit être le sens du travail aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça va être encore un sujet un
sujet qui encore un patron donc au
capitalisme ou se dégager de tout ça
c'est une véritable question aujourd'hui
qui se pose d'ailleurs je note j'ai eu
dans la presse cette semaine qu'il y
avait la moitié des jeunes de 18-24 ans
qui espérait être patron ça veut dire
qu'ils espèrent se libérer de du joug
patronal donc ça c'est vraiment
intéressant et ça veut dire qu'on a on a
vraiment une un travail à faire à ce
niveau là et bien merci beaucoup Joël
Gigou d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je le rappelle vous êtes le nouveau
secrétaire du PC dans les Yvelines alors
comment avoir un beau jardin pour ce
printemps nous nous sommes intéressés à
la question et avons rencontré
pépiniériste fleuriste agriculteur ou
encore horticulteurs ils étaient tous
présents lors de la fête des plantes et
des jardins organisées par le Rotary
club à Montfort-l'Amaury qu'elle plante
choisir comment les entretenir le
reportage de Céline Charles
[Musique]
elles sont rouges blanches roses ou
encore jaunes les plantes et guayes tous
les ans nos paysages de printemps à
montfort-l'amouril à 11e édition de la
Fête des Plantes et Desjardins a battu
son plein ce week-end une cinquantaine
d'exposants ont répondu à l'appel
l'occasion de rappeler au jardinier
chevronnés ou au simple curieux les
consignes pour un beau jardin en cette
saison lui donner de l'amour et un peu
d'eau au printemps on s'occupe déjà de
tout désherber d'enlever le paillage
d'hiver pour prendre histoire qu'on est
protégé nos plantes on commence à
préparer la terre pour le potager on
retourne la terre on peut planter le
pers les fraisiers tous les petits
fruits cassis groseilles
framboise vous pouvez semer des petits
pois attention tout de même à bien
protéger les plantes d'après la croyance
populaire il vaut mieux planter après
les 100 de glace qui ont lieu mi-mai
cette période redoutée des jardiniers
correspond au retour du gel malgré le
redout printanier pour tout ce qui est
plantuel les saints glaces ça peut être
très très fragile et mourir sur le coup
pour un petit coup de gelé quoi on peut
commencer à planter maintenant pour ce
qui est arbuste des choses qui sont
assez résistantes qui ont grandi dans
des gros godets pour ce qui est au
potager ou les petites fleurs style les
géraniums les petites pétunias tout ça
on vaut mieux attendre fin avril début
mai un événement qui permet aussi de
découvrir les bons plans locaux et
écologiques pour son jardin
type des plans de légumes des
aromatiques des plantes médicinales des
fleurs comestibles tout ça en
agriculture biologique donc je suis
certifiée j'utilise de l'eau de cuit
pour l'irrigation je n'utilise pas de
chauffage
à part pour faire germer les semis j'ai
une technique particulière je travaille
en mode donc c'est une technique qui
n'utilise pas d'emballage puisque je
presse des mottes avec une machine
spéciale j'utilise une fourche qui donne
des petites mottes comme ça de terre
tulipes géranium ou bien forsythia
inutile d'avoir la main verte pour s'y
mettre binette et arrosoir n'attendent
que vous
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par Julie Muller bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes la fondatrice de la forest
internationale school on va en parler
dans quelques instants mais d'abord on
va parler de la course Paris camembert
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque petit tour
de table
du fromage voilà
et vous c'est ninja du fromage et du
cyclisme voilà je fais une addition et
bien oui on parle bien de la mythique
course cycliste de 200 km qui relie
l'Île-de-France à la Normandie cela
faisait 8 ans qu'elle n'était pas partie
de Magnanville pour en parler avec nous
le maire de la commune Michel Lebouc
alors selon vous qu'est-ce qui fait le
charme de cette course Paris camembert
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous évoque
après des discussions politiques que
vous avez eu dans votre introduction les
questions de plantation on va parler du
sport et le sport qui est un vecteur
d'émancipation je dis souvent et
notamment par rapport à cette course de
Paris camembert alors il y a camembert
dedans c'est une course mythique
populaire et dans le même temps une
course qui fait partie de la Coupe de
France et la Coupe du Monde de cycliste
donc c'est une véritable institution
qu'on avait perdu depuis quelques années
à Magnanville mais qui a toujours existé
elle partait de Normandie et elle
revient aujourd'hui à Magnanville et
j'en suis très fier pour ma commune bien
entendu mais aussi pour l'institution
que représente le vélo vous le savez
aussi bien que moi c'est que les
Yvelines est une terre de vélo on a eu
le Tour de France l'année dernière à
Mantes-la-Jolie on a eu le départ on a
encore eu le départ de Paris cette année
et on avait le départ du Paris-Nice
l'année dernière
Mantes-la-Jolie aussi donc c'est une
véritable institution qui plus est comme
vous l'avez dit dans votre introduction
les JO arrivant à grands pas on va avoir
l'ensemble des courses des Jeux
Olympiques notamment le PMI la course en
ligne sur notre territoire et c'est
vraiment les Yvelines une terre de vélo
et une terre sportive voilà oui
justement à moins de 500 jours des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 c'est aussi une
manière de faire vivre ce sport le vélo
dans votre commune dans votre ville
tout à fait comme je vous le disais
c'est une véritable institution les gens
aiment bien être le long de la route
regardez le Tour de France regardez les
cyclistes passés et puis aussi on a un
bon nombre de bénévoles on a une
association à Magnanville et qui
travaille beaucoup dans le cadre de du
cyclo et c'est vraiment important pour
nous de reprendre cette course et
j'insiste là-dessus qui est une course
très mythique et qui nous fait du bien à
tous dans ce monde où l'actualité
sociale et économique est un peu
perturbée c'est vraiment un
souffle qu'on va donner à l'ensemble des
manières-villoise et des
manières-villois de nos associations et
dans le même temps du territoire du
Mantois alors au total ces équipes qui
vont s'élancer sur un parcours de 200 km
pour rejoindre livaro Pays d'Auge dans
le département du Calvados avec de très
grands noms de grands coureurs de grands
sportifs
oui alors il y a eu des grands noms des
grands sportifs qui ont gagné cette
course mythique notamment pour les cités
Bernard Hinault il y a eu Laurent Fignon
pour ceux qui se rappellent de l'époque
yops automnalesk on a aussi un yvelinois
qui est très connu syndicasa donc il
fait partie du comité d'organisation que
je salue qui qui est toujours resté en
terre menteuse étant donné que c'est un
mentait pure source qui a gagné une fois
simplement cette course au mythique qui
est arrivé je crois de mémoire deux ou
trois fois deuxième mais c'est vraiment
l'excellence du cyclisme qu'on connaît
en France et les valeurs portées par le
par le vélo
et donc cette course elle est partenaire
avec la marque de camembert le petit il
y aura des dégustations pour les plus
gourmands
tout à fait donc on a assez une
organisation et je salue toute mon
équipe l'équipe de Paris camembert et
mon équipe municipale notamment et le
département des Yvelines la communauté
urbaine Grand Paris senew Oise qui nous
ont aidé à construire à cette course
parce que c'est c'est des moyens quand
même conséquents bien entendu ça va
commencer à partir de 9h30 de mémoire le
11 avril ou le public pourra déambuler
et rencontrer les coureurs
professionnels il y aura aussi bien
entendu comme vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est Paris camembert mais je vois sur
il y aura pas que du camembert bien
entendu il y aura d'autres surprises il
y a des ateliers recyclistes des
entretiens de réparation vélo on va
faire venir nos écoles qui doivent nous
permettre d'en même temps de donner une
dynamique par rapport à cette course
mais d'ailleurs pourquoi une marque de
camembert de fromage et partenaire de
cette d'une course de vélo
alors à l'époque sachez-le c'était
vraiment c'est comme le parimente je
sais pas si vous connaissez la marche à
pied pariment on dit Paris manque mais
ça part c'est parti de Versailles la
Paris gammembert parti à l'époque de la
de la cabine ancienne communauté
admiration de menthe-en-yvelines et donc
Paris camembert parce qu'il y a une
ville qui s'appelle camembert et les
coureurs arrivaient à camembert
aujourd'hui ça sera plus camembert il y
a ça sera comment une ville
Vivaro juste à côté livaro marque aussi
de fromage mais le camembert le petit a
toujours été le partenaire principal de
7% voilà et alors sur le parcours il y
aura aussi quelques quelques côtes un
peu traditionnels avec 15% de dénivelé
tout à fait alors là moi je suis je dis
souvent j'aime le vélo mais le vélo ne
m'aime pas je suis un ancien rugbyman
sachez le feu donc c'est toujours
compliqué mais moi j'ai pu participer à
l'époque dans la voiture du directeur de
course à cette montée à 15 % même à pied
je pense que je la ferai pas alors il y
a plusieurs côtes qui sont de
l'ordre de 10 entre 10 et 15% mais ça va
être vraiment terrible pour les couleurs
pour les coureurs voilà
et bien merci beaucoup Michel le bouc
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors
Paris camembert c'est lancera donc de
Magnanville le mardi 11 avril à 10h45
devant l'hôtel de ville il y aura
également un village avec des animations
tout à fait plan d'animation pour les
petits les les adultes et puis les
années qui sont je dirais cher vend du
vélo comme on le voit le long des routes
du Tour de France et on estime avoir et
on espère surtout avoir beaucoup
beaucoup de monde à ce départ même si
c'est le mardi de Pâques ou on sait que
les gens sont au travail mais on sait
d'ores et déjà qu'on a des centaines et
des centaines de personnes qui viendront
au départ de la Corse et bien
rendez-vous mardi prochain à 10h45 à
Magnanville on va parler d'éducation à
présent avec une nouvelle chronique
présentée par notre journaliste Régine
ralech et du Talk et pour ce premier
numéro on va parler de la forest
internationale School et donc nous
sommes justement avec la fondatrice de
cette école Julie Muller Régine est-ce
que vous pouvez nous présenter en
quelques mots qu'est-ce que cette école
forest internationale School et oui
Mathilde alors cette école elle a été
créée en 2004 et elle est basée à Marly
près de Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est une
école privée hors contraste c'est-à-dire
qu'elle n'a pas signé d'accord avec
l'État cette école est propose également
un programme bilingue donc à 70% en
anglais et quelques autres cours en
français et pourquoi bilingue parce que
c'est une école qui s'adresse
majoritairement à des enfants de parents
expatriés alors ce qui fait également la
particularité de cette école c'est son
apprentissage par le mouvement et son
apprentissage en extérieur alors je vous
rassure tous les cours ne sont pas à
l'extérieur il y a aussi des cours en
classe à l'intérieur mais sur place
quand moi je m'y suis rendue il y avait
par exemple ce professeur de
mathématiques qui enseignait ses élèves
comment se servir des mathématiques pour
par exemple construire des matériaux et
donc les élèves vont par exemple déjà
construit des carillons avant avec des
bambous ou même des prototypes
d'aspirateur pour savoir à peu près
comment ça fonctionne et je dirais
également que la force de cette école
c'est aussi la différenciation
pédagogique mais alors c'est quoi la
différenciation pédagogique alors la
différenciation pédagogique excusez moi
alors c'est dans une classe il y a des
élèves avec des capacités et des modes
d'apprentissage différent et donc
l'enseignant lui justement va prendre en
compte toutes ces particularités les
forces et les faiblesses de ces élèves
et j'ai justement c'est l'école qui va
s'adapter à l'élève et non l'inverse
alors évidemment c'est une chose qui est
possible à la forest International
School pourquoi parce que les classes
sont peu nombreuses elles sont composées
entre 8 et 12 élèves et vous vous y êtes
rendu la semaine dernière justement vous
avez interviewé les parents et les
professeurs on regarde tout de suite
votre reportage
[Musique]
un des choses que j'aime le plus chez
Forest National c'est que la pensée
critique est mise au centre de tout ce
que j'aime c'est
pas vous encourager à penser qu'est-ce
que je peux faire avec ce savoir-faire
qu'est-ce que je peux construire avec ce
savoir-faire normalement
[Musique]
salut alors Julie Muller on le voit dans
cette vidéo on entend de l'anglais de
l'espagnol combien de nationalités
avez-vous au sein de votre école on a 22
nationalités à l'école à l'école pour
l'Ouest il y a beaucoup de monde du
enfin les gens viennent du monde entier
et et on accueille des familles avec des
enfants qui ne parlent pas
nécessairement ni en gagnant français et
voilà du fait des petites effectifs on
va pouvoir les intégrer rapidement ils
apprennent très très vite parler
l'anglais et le français justement le
programme est bilingue majoritairement
en anglais j'imagine j'imagine que pour
certains l'anglais ça peut quand même
poser quelques problèmes c'est pas trop
compliqué
pour certains élèves
non pas plus que d'apprendre le français
enfin en accueille des enfants du monde
entier donc pour eux c'est une langue
étrangère comme une autre
et alors justement je dis Muller des
écoles de ce type on en trouve pas
énormément en France si on en compte
actuellement une trentaine est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu la
genèse de cette école et pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez décidé d'ouvrir une école
de ce type donc Forrest International
School on l'a créé à 19 ans avec ma mère
et l'idée c'était de créer une école où
les enfants et du plaisir à venir avec
qu'ils arrivent le matin avec un grand
sourire et
on a commencé tout petit on avait une
classe et petit à petit on a on a créé
des nouveaux espaces et des nouvelles
classes les nouveaux bâtiments
l'idée c'est de créer une école avec ou
un incorpore l'extérieur avec les
classes donc on va apprendre on va
enseigner aux enfants les
les matières académiques le matin par
exemple et quelques après-midi par
semaine on va faire des activités comme
ce que vous avez montré là à l'extérieur
en forêt ou alors dans le dans
l'enceinte de l'école et justement vous
le disiez donc il y a une place
importante de la nature pourquoi est-ce
que vous jugez que c'est important
aujourd'hui pour les enfants de passer
du temps à l'extérieur c'est essentiel
vous avez parlé de la différenciation
travailler à l'extérieur c'est
travailler sur des projets concrets et
en travaillant comme ça à l'extérieur on
peut différencier c'est à dire qu'on
peut s'adresser aux différents types
d'apprentissage des enfants les
différents intelligences et on peut
faire du multi niveau
aujourd'hui bien sûr il y a une réalité
en termes d'environnement et le fait de
les sortir tous les jours aller en forêt
ça permet d'observer les petits détails
aller voir les insectes voir comment la
faune et la flore évolue donc là
actuellement en forêt il y a des il y a
plein de plantes et des bourgeons des
bourgeons qui sortent et donc ce qu'on
veut faire c'est vraiment permettre à
l'enfant d'être
en symbiose avec son environnement et de
prendre le temps d'observer parce qu'on
y a énormément d'apprentissage
potentiels à l'extérieur du coup cette
pédagogie elle se casse un petit peu
avec la pédagogie traditionnelle qu'on
connaît en tout cas dans les écoles
publiques
est-ce que justement comme vous êtes une
école hors contrat est-ce que vous avez
tout de même des obligations envers
l'éducation nationale comment est-ce que
ça ça marche tout à fait alors on est
obligé de passer par eux pour
l'ouverture de l'école c'est une demande
d'affaires auprès du rectorat ensuite on
se fait inspecter quasiment chaque année
et il faut montrer des diplômes de tous
les professeurs et il faut vraiment
soutenir déjà la candidature quand on
l'ouvre l'école mais par la suite il
faut vraiment
montrer carte blanche
carte blanche c'est à dire il faut être
en règle vis-à-vis de l'accessibilité
les pompiers passent etc donc il faut
vraiment être complètement en règle tout
comme les établissements publics mais
vous avez quand même une bonne marge de
liberté
où c'est complètement différent en terme
de de maths d'histoire-géographie nous
suivons internationale school on suit le
curriculum anglais donc il y a des
similitudes avec avec ce qui se fait en
France par contre il faut montrer des
parallèles et montrer que par exemple
les multiplications dans les anciennes
plus ou moins le même au même âge après
en Europe les choses les programmes sont
quasiment les mêmes
et sont assez l'uniformes mais non il
faut il faut vraiment jouer le jeu alors
même si on fait pas partie de du réseau
il faut
et voilà il faut il faut montrer qu'on
est
quand on fait des apprentissages et qui
a des similitudes avec le système
français il y a justement en parlant de
système français de système anglais en
allant sur place j'ai interviewé
justement une maman donc Annabelle
Roberts elle est canadienne et elle vit
en France depuis 2008 et elle m'a dit
avoir été assez surprise du système en
France pour elle en France les filières
scientifiques et les métiers
d'ingénierie sont souvent mis en avant
et justement la question que que je me
pose c'est est-ce que vous c'est quelque
chose que vous prenez en compte parce
que ce qu'elle me dit ce qu'elle aime en
tout cas dans cette école c'est la
reconnaissance des intelligences
multiples et l'égalité des talents
est-ce que c'est des retours qu'on vous
fait régulièrement au sein de votre
école tout à fait d'ailleurs on a même
des enfants qui se pensaient très mateux
et finalement ils sont très mateux et au
fait très artistique aussi donc en donne
la possibilité à chaque enfant de
d'explorer plein de choses différentes
et de construire et et de mettre en
pratique des choses
très théoriques à la base et voilà donc
il y a des révélations pour certains
enfants et justement cette école aussi
elle elle propose donc cette variété de
pédagogie est-ce qu'à votre avis il y
aurait aujourd'hui des solutions à
mettre en place dans les écoles
publiques parce qu'on sait que votre
école est assez onéreuse est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a des choses à faire en
tout cas dans le saignement public de
manière adaptée sans forcément dépenser
des sommes oui je pense que je pense que
chaque professeur est en capacité de
pouvoir incorporer de l'extérieur dans
son dans son quotidien alors peut-être
pas tous les jours mais par exemple je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup d'écoles donc
sous contrat d'État qui le mercredi le
mercredi sur deux pour faire des
activités à l'extérieur ou en forêt
c'est quelque chose qui se planifie qui
peut tout à fait s'organiser
après il faut avoir de l'intérêt pour la
chose et regarder en ligne tout est
accessible en ligne il y a plein d'idées
et voilà il faut juste y aller et avoir
l'idée de le faire je pense que c'est
possible d'ailleurs j'encourage tout le
monde à le faire plus d'être plus à
l'extérieur vous en c'est quoi de cette
école Joël gigouzeau
c'est clair c'est c'est une école privée
moi je suis plutôt pour l'école
publiquement intégrant une partie de ce
que ce qu'a dit
la référence mais je suis vraiment pour
que l'école publique joue totalement
sans rôle il fasse réussir les élèves
quoi voilà et là c'est bon dans ce
cas-là c'est pas le cas d'inspiration
pour l'éducation nationale
pourquoi pas mais ça l'éducation
nationale pour moi c'est vraiment la
seule qui peut qui peut faire réussir
mais l'ensemble des élèves dans les
quartiers populaires comme dans les
quartiers riches tout à fait d'ailleurs
il faut savoir que ce type de
d'enseignement dans certains pays c'est
pas réservé aux écoles privées mais
c'est vraiment incorporé dans les écoles
publiques notamment en Angleterre donc
on n'a pas besoin de laisser ce petit
d'école à des privilégiés et je pense
que justement il faudrait s'inspirer
d'autres pays pour vraiment proposer
des activités alternatives et d'autres
pédagogies plus innovantes pour déjà
capturer l'intérêt des enfants parce que
chaque enfant a le droit et mérite
d'avoir une bonne scolarité une des
questions intéressante
est-ce que vous avez pour projet
d'ouvrir d'autres écoles en France pour
l'instant non
mais pas d'objectif dans ce sens des
écoles des écoles comme les miennes pour
l'instant non mais pourquoi pas enfin il
existe plusieurs écoles de type forest
cours en France mais elles sont souvent
réservées au mercredi ou samedi et déjà
notre modèle il est un peu hybride parce
qu'on a des classes et des salles de
classe donc les enfants passent de la
classe à l'extérieur mais la vraie
forest cours en Angleterre dans les pays
nordiques tout se passe à l'extérieur et
bien merci beaucoup
à nos questions donc je le rappelle vous
êtes la directrice de la forêt school
internationale school Régine ralech du
coup vous revenez la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle chronique et du Talk
tout à fait je reviens pour parler d'une
association la courte échelle qui est
notamment les élèves à mieux s'insérer
dans la filière de la justice donc ce
sera la semaine prochaine on sera là
pour pour écouter tout ça ça a l'air
très intéressant on va maintenant
prendre la direction de Versailles et
plus précisément du Trianon Palace
l'hôtel de luxe propose deux journées
inédites pour le week-end de Pâques avec
notamment une création spéciale du chef
pâtissier Eddy benganet mais un petit
time inédit le reportage de Michael et
demi d'euro
la reine des abeilles a l'honneur au
très long Palace de Versailles pour
Pâques Eddie benghane proposera cette
année une cinquantaine de créations
chocolatées elles seront vendues au
tarif de 49 euros clients de l'hôtel et
de l'extérieur le chef pâtissier
installé dans l'hôtel depuis 14 ans vous
les rappeler les souvenirs d'enfance et
plaire au plus jeunes enfants pas que
c'est Maya l'abeille pour nous cette
année c'est vrai qu'on s'est à chaque
fois qu'on l'apprend on la prend en
photo Maya l'abeille on l'a tous un
sourire parce qu'elle est trop drôle
elle a des lunettes bon ben peut-être un
petit peu de ressemblance avec moi ce
que j'aime bien les lunettes mais elle
est drôle elle est elle est rigolote et
elle parle à plein de générations
différentes c'est aussi notre symbole
donc le symbole du Trianon de Versailles
de la royauté et l'abeille c'est quelque
chose de très très important le lundi 10
avril 8 personnes vont également
travailler sur un grand after un outil
en 7 séquences salées et sucrées qui
sera proposé dans le salon Clemenceau
dans l'assiette vous pourrez notamment
déguster une tarte au petit pois et à la
burrata un pinceau fait à l'encre de
seiche concombre et saumon fumé il y a
un moelleux noisette et poire on fait
souvent des repas entre nous et je me
suis dit ça serait super sympa d'avoir
une séquence complète pour être cohérent
constant et puis participer aussi à
l'expérience et comment voilà comment
peut-on faire un peu plus pour nos
clients comment peut-on plus les leur
faire plaisir les choyer et les
chouchouter quoi ce petit time se retard
de 75 euros pour les adultes et 40 euros
pour les enfants en parallèle des
animations seront également proposées
pour les plus jeunes pour la journée
dans cet hôtel historique créé en 1910
alors est-ce que ça vous donne envie de
goûter en plateau toujours c'est clair
c'est clair mais à notre époque où
l'inflation galopante ça va être dur de
rassembler
le teaime
invité mais je sais que de plus en plus
de tels qui font ce genre de prestation
et s'appelait énormément et finalement
c'est pas plus mal que ce soit ici à
Versailles plutôt qu'à Paris en tout cas
ça a l'air très bon
et pour avoir déjà goûté un petit time
de du chef Eddie benganen c'est c'est
très très bon je vous le conseille si
vous avez les fonds allez c'est l'heure
de parler cinéma à présent les films à
ne pas manquer cette semaine quel est le
coup de coeur signé de notre réalisateur
yvelinois on fait le point tout de suite
et on commence cette page cinéma avec le
coup de coeur d'un réalisateur yvelinois
ce soir c'est Thomas Salazar qui nous
partage son coup de coeur pour un film
humoristique regardez
[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous
parlais de mon coup de cœur cinéma c'est
le film qui veut la peau de Roger Rabbit
réalisé par Robert Zemeckis en 1988 la
spécificité de ce film c'est que c'est
le premier à utiliser la prise de vue
réelle et le dessin animé comme le fera
plus tard Space Jam ou Arthur et les
Minimoys par exemple et la force de
Robert Zemeckis c'est d'arriver à rendre
le cartoon cartoonesque mais de rendre
aussi la prise de vue réelle donc le
film avec les acteurs vraiment tout
aussi cartoonesque en termes de rythme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un détective privé
spécialiste dans les affaires de Toon
les toons c'est les petits dessins
animés les petits personnages qui va
devoir protéger la grande star du
cartoon le lapin Roger Rabbit c'est
plein d'humour c'est plein de références
à ceux qui aiment les cartoon des années
80 en termes de réalisation c'est aussi
très original avec ce procédé cartoon
vidéo c'est quand même réalisé par
Robert Zemeckis celui qui a fait
redourait le futur et Forrest Gump donc
c'est quelqu'un qui qui sait s'y faire
dans le cinéma on rit c'est pour tous
les âges pour les parents pour les
enfants tout le monde il trouvera son
bonheur je vous conseille de voir qui
veut la peau de Roger Rabbit de Robert
Zemeckis
[Musique]
on poursuit cette page cinéma avec vous
Céline Charles comme tous les mercredis
on fait le point sur les sorties ciné de
la semaine et ce soir on commence par un
petit personnage moustachu en salopette
que nous connaissons tous très bien il
va faire son apparition sur le grand
écran et oui vous l'avez peut-être connu
avec cette description on parle bien sûr
de Mario Bros ce personnage
iconique de Nintendo qu'on avait plutôt
l'habitude de voir sur nos consoles de
jeux après un premier film raté il y a
30 ans le plombier revient avec une
toute nouvelle adaptation cette fois-ci
réalisée par les studios illuminations à
qui l'on doit à la saga moi moche et
méchant par exemple dans ce film on
retrouve tous les personnages
emblématiques de l'univers du jeu Mario
Luigi le champignon Toad ou encore la
princesse Peach Mario et son frère Luigi
tous deux plombier se retrouve aspiré
par un mystérieux tuyau qui les emmène
tout droit dans un univers parallèle
effet Éric Luigi disparaît Mario va
devoir alors s'engager dans une aventure
un petit peu folle pour le retrouver
dans sa quête il va devoir affronter le
méchant et emblématique Bowser regardez
le Royaume Champignon
[Applaudissements]
sera bientôt là je n'ai pas peur je
ferai n'importe quoi pour mon frère on
va réussir à le sauver
c'est parti
[Musique]
une autre grande sortie cette semaine
Céline le classique d'Alexandre Dumas
revient sur nos écrans mais le premier
volet inspiré du roman célèbre les trois
mousquetaires sort ce mercredi alors le
livre a été adapté une trentaine de fois
sur le grand écran mais le réalisateur
Martin bourvoulon a souhaité tout de
même donner un vent nouveau à cette
histoire on suivra bien sûr les
aventures du jeune d'Artagnan monter à
Paris pour servir le roi et entrer au
service de l'unité d'élite des
Mousquetaires il va se retrouver
entraîner dans un complot cherchant à
discréditer la reine et qui prépare
l'invasion de la France par l'Angleterre
regardé
qui est cet enfant d'Artagnan Votre
Majesté
trois duels ou trois heures avec trois
mousquetaires monsieur Atos a le droit
de me tuer en premier monsieur Porto son
second et Aramis en dernier je vous prie
de m'excuser par avance si je ne peux
contenter tout le monde
[Musique]
je me trouve bien arrogant jeune homme
c'est ma seule richesse et je la mets
tout entière au service de sa majesté
que puis-je faire pour son fils ou six
mois que je me souvienne j'ai toujours
voulu être mousquetaire
et peut-être un jour
et on vient de le voir on y retrouve
quelques visages familiers Vincent
Cassel Eva Green François civil romain
Dury son corps pur marmel pour ne pas
les citer la seconde partie les trois
mousquetaires millési sortira le 13
décembre prochain un très beau casting
effectivement on termine cette sélection
avec une romance à suspense inspirer de
faits réel Céline il s'agit de c'est mon
homme réalisé par Guillaume bureau ce
film porté par Karim les clous Leila
Bekhti et Louise Bourgoin mais en scène
un soldat revenu amnésique de la guerre
14-18 il retrouve alors Julie persuadée
de reconnaître son mari et qui bien sûr
heureuse de le retrouver veut tout faire
pour lui faire recouvrir la mémoire mais
les choses se corsent lorsque une autre
femme entre dans le tableau et assure
qu'il est son époux dans le film la
question et donc de savoir qui des deux
femmes et sa vraie femme une situation
une situation compliquée
merci beaucoup Céline Charles petit tour
de plateau qu'est-ce qu'il y a un film
qui vous tente plus qu'un autre
des petits enfants maintenant je saurai
merci
et vous Julie le premier parce qu'en
effet j'avais vu qu'on est sorti début
des années 90 et j'ai pas vu depuis donc
moi ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
que en fait d'habitude bah Mario part
rechercher pitch et en fait là cette
fois-ci il part chercher Luigi donc ça
casse un peu les codes plus de
fraternité que d'amour peut-être
visiblement
il faut Régine une préférence et moi
pour compléter je serais plutôt
intéressée par c'est mon homme parce que
je suis assez curieuse de savoir comment
ils vont se dépatouiller dans cette
histoire
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant de se quitter je tends
un dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
demain matin prévoyez vos parapluies
météo France annonce de la pluie sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera 8 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Versailles et
7° à Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le
temps s'améliore du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan avec quelques
éclaircies des averses sont toujours à
prévoir dans le secteur de Versailles et
Rambouillet côté température il fera en
moyenne 11 à 12 degrés dans les Yvelines
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]